Пане Пофалла, наскільки широкою буде майбутня співпраця між Deutsche Bahn і "Укрзалізницею"?
Йдеться суто про консалтинг,
и Deutsche Bahn братиме участь в ухваленні  управлінських рішень?
Спочатку дійсно йтиметься про консультування.
І вже залежно від того, наскільки успішним буде консалтинг,
можуть бути впроваджені подальші кроки.
Але чи дійде до цього, залежить якраз від того,
чи вдасться нам знайти точки дотику
в процесі консультування.
Адже врешті-решт немає сенсу вести розмови
про управління українською залізницею,
якщо вже на першому етапі консультування не буде досягнуто спільних результатів.
Тож я б сказав, що зараз, під час першого кроку,
йдеться, по суті, про консультування, а вже потім, якщо воно матиме успіх,
можливо, йтиметься про те, щоб кілька
наших менеджерів
підтримали керівництво "Укрзалізниці" в процесі управління.
Тобто управління "Укрзалізницею", як і раніше, здійснюватиметься самими українцями,
але буде підсилене нашими менеджерами.
Чи є вже, крім меморандуму, який було підписано, дорожня карта співпраці?
Вже відомо, якими будуть наступні кроки?
Дорожньою картою, мабуть, буде те, що ми після підписання
маємо домовитись і, можливо, зафіксувати письмово,
про яку форму консалтингових послуг йдеться,
оскільки це необхідно з юридичної точки зору.
Але ми вважаємо, що починати треба швидко,
якщо цього хочуть українці.
Що Deutsche Bahn, як найбільший залізничний концерн Європи,
може запропонувати "Укрзалізниці"?
Який досвід?
Ми самі пройшли вже два трансформаційні процеси.
Колишню Deutsche Bundesbahn
у Федеративній Республіці Німеччина
і стару Reichsbahn з колишньої НДР
на початку 90-х років було об'єднано,
а у 1994 році приватизовано.
І якщо Ви подивитесь на тогочасну статистику,
то побачите, що обидві залізниці разом налічували
понад 700 тисяч співробітників,
а зараз залізниця у Німеччині налічує 210 тисяч працівників.
І з цього видно, що цей процес трансформації,
перехід від державних залізниць до підприємств,
що працюють як приватні компанії і є конкурентоспроможними на ринку -
це 25 років історії Deutsche Bahn AG у Німеччині.
Ви не могли б назвати декілька прикладів такого роду партнерства
бо співпраці з іншими країнами?
DB Engineering & Consulting, котра як дочірнє підприємство DB AG
забезпечує організацію, працює як компанія з консалтингу
і планування з 1966 року,
тобто має понад 50 років досвіду
у консалтингових процесах.
DB Engineering & Consulting активна по всьому світу,
але вона консультує і нас самих у Німеччині.
Тобто ця компанія здійснює планування і для нас у Німеччині,
і є успішною у всьому світі.
Ми маємо подібні проекти в окремих країнах, приміром, у Казахстані,
де ми надаємо схожі послуги з консалтингу і підтримки,
які зараз мають надаватись в Україні.
Необхідність яких саме змін
Ви вбачаєте на "Укрзалізниці"?
Наразі я можу оцінювати лише загальні дані, про які я читав,
тому я хотів би бути обережним у формулюваннях,
оскільки цього, звісно, недостатньо для кваліфікованої оцінки.
Але вже на основі загальних даних можна побачити,
що з економічної точки зору є потреба в оптимізації
і що є можливості економічної оптимізації, які мають бути реалізовані.
Як Ви оцінюєте потенціал і перспективи
розвитку "Укрзалізниці"?
Україна має дуже широко розвинену мережу залізничних шляхів
загальною протяжністю 22-23 тисячі кілометрів.
Це - одна з найбільших мереж у Європі.
Тобто з цієї точки зору вона є значущою.
З іншого боку, особливістю України є те,
що доволі значну роль відіграють
вантажні перевезення,
в той час як у Західній Європі більша частка припадає на пасажирські перевезення
Ви бачите в Україні політичну волю провести реформу "Укрзалізниці"?
Так, однозначно.
Прем'єр-міністр щойно знову говорив про це зі мною і чітко дав зрозуміти,
що він і його уряд прагнуть трансформацій.
Він навіть підкреслив, що узгодив це із президентом.
Отже, я виходжу з того, що те, що зараз відбуватиметься,
є бажаним і буде підтримуватись політично.
Останнє запитання. Що буде наступним кроком після підписання Меморандуму?
Вже відома дата наступної зустрічі?
Ні. Наступним кроком буде те, що обидві сторони,
"Укрзалізниця" і Deutsche Bahn з DB Engineering & Consulting як посередником,
повинні зустрітись і обговорити, як цей проект
може бути реалізований та яка послуга і коли має бути надана.
Ми намагатимемося погодити це відносно швидко.
Пане Пофалла, дякую Вам за розмову!